foreign
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you Dave thank you Christina I got
my gazelle card a few weeks ago I'm
holding up the high right now
all right we need to put like a light on
it so you can hold it up like a cell
phone right have a concert all right
what's up man how can we help
yeah Dave so I'm moving from DC to
Greenville South Carolina
um we're looking to buy a home in
December and then selling our current
home in DC in February I've listened to
the real estate reality check I read the
blog post I think you put out a month
like a month after that
I'm just still worried you know
um it might sound ridiculous but I just
I'm still worried about housing prices
crashing getting stuck in between two
houses everything like that I'd love to
hear some more of your thoughts on that
some more reassurance
well I mean
since Washington continues to layer
stupid upon stupid there's a lot of
reason for us to uh be a little worried
I mean it's you know you just keep
watching them I mean how many more dumb
things can you people do up there
um and so I not you personally but I'm
just saying DC you know the the
politicians the freaking White House has
lost its mind economically it's the
worst economy inflation wise in 40 years
so yeah I can understand you being
concerned I mean I kind of look over my
shoulder and I know the data and I'm
real comfortable with the facts but your
emotions do creep up on you I don't
blame you for that I I can understand
that
um I went and talked to one of my
friends as a custom home builder this
weekend and he goes
yeah it changed because I got no
customers
he could they were lined up around the
block and he's got no customers so um
yeah it's changed and he's talking about
stuff building that building stuff next
summer you know that kind of a thing uh
uh a year from now and so that which is
not far from your time frame so but all
that to say
yeah I emotionally agree with you but
the facts are still there
there is still four buyers for every
house that's up for sale
uh the facts recent data as you know I
started I read two articles on the air
yesterday George and I did that um that
are coming out with fresh data even out
of California which is really
experiencing some problems because of
the mass Exodus
um and we've got a California Refugee
problem in Tennessee and so
um
uh but the uh uh you know there still is
affecting things but the uh
uh the data Nationwide for Greenville
South Carolina and for uh Arlington
Virginia is still that there's about
four buyers for every house that's for
sale uh now that they're not as active
and they're not as frenzied as they were
but that was an unusual frenzy for about
two and a half years we went through
there
I've been in the real estate business
since 1978 I've never seen people act
like that before
usually it takes about 90 days to sell a
house and you're going to get a couple
of offers and none of them are full
price
you know and that's a normal house
selling process over the last 40 or 50
years you're going to experience that
and you don't have to rush over and
overpay for something when you get to
Greenville South Carolina you're going
to be able to walk around look at houses
and make an offer and think about it and
you know use a normal buying process too
now what I would do and I would do this
in any economy is I would not buy a
house until yours is sold
yeah that's what I was wondering what is
the what's the reasoning for buying a
December and selling in February
just the slow process of moving my
wife's wrapping up her job so it's it's
that really
um she's from Greenville South Carolina
so we know it very well I mean I've been
there probably once or twice every year
once or twice a year for the last 10
years so
um I just kind of want to do if you end
up with two house payments you're going
to become what's called a motivated
seller
well the other house is almost paid off
so I can probably write a check today
and pay it off okay well if you want to
pay it off and sit on it but but here's
the thing even that with it sitting up
there empty and you're paying taxes and
insurance and utilities and you got to
keep it all nice and proper so it can be
shown uh you're going to reach a point
emotionally that you become a motivated
seller I want I want rid of this thing I
want that chapter of my life closed so
be real careful with that because you I
don't want you to give it away because
of the because you create a situation
for yourself
so I I I personally would rethink that
and say I'm not buying until mine sells
and if that means you rent for six
months in Greenville or you do some
other plan
uh you do some uh corporate housing in
Arlington because you sell the house out
from under yourself in December uh and
your wife has some things to close up
then that's fine but I'm going to change
the logistics to flip-flop on that where
I buy 90 days after I sell or at least
nine days after I sell and that'll take
a lot of stress off of this
hey good question man thanks for letting
us discuss it this is the Ramsay show